The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Last time we were
talking about the hair cells.
And there's a picture
of a hair cell here.
And what did we do
about the hair cells?
We talked about the two types,
inner hair cells-- plain old,
ordinary receptor cells.
And we talked about
outer hair cells,
which have this
wonderful characteristic
of electromotility.
When their hair bundle
is bent back and forth,
their internal
potential changes.
When they're depolarized,
the cell shortens.
And somehow this
mechanical shortening
adds to the vibrations
of the organ of Corti
and basilar membrane that
were set up by sound.
And it amplifies
those vibrations
so that the inner
hair cells then
are responding to an
amplified vibration.
And the outer hair
cells are then
dubbed by the name of
the cochlear amplifier.
Without the amplification,
you lose 40 to 60 dB
of hearing, which
is a big amount.
A large hearing
loss would result
if you didn't have
outer hair cells
or without their
electromotility, which
were shown by deleting
the gene for Preston
and testing the knockout
mouse, which had a 40 to 60
dB hearing loss.
So questions about that?
Before we talked about
the two hair cells,
we talked about vibration in the
cochlear, what of tuning curve
is.
In that case for tuning
of the basilar membrane,
a particular point
along the cochlear--
so you could bring your
measurement device to one
particular place and measure
its tuning in response to sounds
of different
frequencies, and show
that a single
place vibrates very
nicely to a
particular frequency.
That is you don't have
to send in very much
sound into the ear.
But if you go off that
particular frequency,
you have to boost
the sound a lot
to get that one
place to vibrate.
And we had the example
of the vibration patterns
that low frequencies stimulated
the cochlear apex the most, way
up near the top of
the snail shell.
And middle frequencies
stimulated the middle.
And high frequencies
stimulated the basal part.
We'll be talking a lot
more about that frequency
organization along
the cochlear today,
when we talk about
auditory nerve fibers.
So here's a roadmap for today.
We're going to concentrate
on the auditory nerve.
And I just put down
some numbers so I
wouldn't forget to tell
you how many auditory nerve
fibers there are.
There are approximately
30,000 auditory nerve fibers
in humans.
So that means in your
left ear you have 30,000.
And in you're right ear you
have 30,000 sending messages
from the ear to the brain.
So that's a pretty
hefty number, right?
How many optic
nerve fibers do you
have or does a primate have?
I'm sure Dr. Schiller
went over that number.
We're pretty visual on animals.
So our sense of vision
is well developed.
So how many nerve fibers
go from the retina
into the brain compared
to this number?
Anybody remember?
Well, that's a good
number to remember.
It turns out there about 1
million optic nerve fibers
from the retina into the brain.
And here we have 30,000.
So which is the most important
sense, vision or audition?
Or which sense conveys
messages more efficiently,
should we say?
Well, obviously, primates
are very visual animals.
So we have a lot more nerve
fibers sending messages
into the brain about
vision than we do audition.
So I may not have given you
numbers for the hair cells.
In humans we have about
3,500 inner hair cells
and about 12,000 outer
hair cells per cochlea.
OK, so those are the numbers.
So today, we'll talk about
the two types of nerve fibers.
As we have two
types of hair cells,
we have two types
of nerve fibers.
We'll talk about
tuning curves now
for the responses of
auditory nerve fibers.
And we'll talk about
tonotopic organization.
That is organization
of frequency
to place within
the cochlea, which
is one of the codes
for sound frequency.
How do we know we're listening
to 1,000 Hertz and not 2,000
Hertz by which place
along the cochlea
and which group of auditory
nerve fibers is responding.
Then we'll get away
from auditory nerve
and have some listening
demonstrations.
We'll see how good we
are at discriminating
two frequencies that
are very close together.
And we'll talk about
some tuning curves
that are based on
psychophysical measure.
That is listening.
You can take some tuning curves
by just a human listener.
Then we'll get back
to auditory nerve
and talk about a different
code for sound frequency.
That is the temporal code
for sound frequency, which
involves a phenomenon
called phase
locking of the auditory nerve.
Then we'll talk
about how that's very
important in your listening
to musical intervals.
And the most important
musical interval
is the octave, so we'll have
a demonstration of an octave.
OK, so one of my problems as I
pass by the MIT Coop on the way
to class, and I
always buy something.
So I did a reading last week.
And so we'll have a little
reading from this book,
I Am Malala.
She was the girl who was
shot right and recovered
and was a candidate for
the Nobel Peace Prize.
Maybe next year she'll
get the Peace Prize.
I haven't read this.
I just picked it up
a few minutes ago.
But I went straight to the
section about her surgery.
So she was shot in
the head on one side.
And she said, "While
I was in surgery--"
this is after recovery.
This is a further
surgery she underwent.
"While I was in surgery,
Mr. Irving, the surgeon who
had repaired my nerve--"
that's her facial nerve--
"also had a solution for
my damaged left ear drum.
He put a small electronic
device called a cochlear implant
inside my head near the ear,
and told me that in a month
they would fit the
external part on my head.
And then I should be able
to hear from that ear."
OK, so the cochlear
implant is a device
that stimulates the
auditory nerve fibers.
And in a person who's
had a gunshot wound--
either because of the loud
sound or the mechanical trauma
to the ear or temporal
bone-- possibly
the hair cells are damaged
or are completely missing.
And the auditory
nerve fibers remain.
The person is deaf
without the hair cells.
But the device called
the cochlear implant
can be inserted inside
this person's cochlear
to stimulate the auditory nerve.
And we'll have a discussion of
the cochlear implant next week
when we have a demonstrator
come to class who's deaf.
And she'll show you
about her implant.
But we do need to know a
lot about the auditory nerve
response before we can
really think about what
is the good coding strategy
for cochlear implant.
That is how do we take
the sound information
and translate it
into the shocks that
are provided by the cochlear
implant electrodes that
stimulate the nerve fibers.
Because little electric
currents in the cochlear implant
are made to stimulate
the auditory nerve fibers
that can then send
messages to the brain.
So it's just a little
motivator for what's
important about
auditory nerve code.
So we'll start out today
with the hair cells.
And these are the
auditory nerves here.
One thing that's interesting
about vision and audition
is the look of the
synapse between the hair
cell and the nerve fiber, and
between the photoreceptor--
you have rods and
cones in the retina.
And they have associated
nerve terminals here.
And these are
electron micrographs,
taken with a very high powered
electron microscope that
looks at the synapse between
the photoreceptor up here
or the hair cell up here and the
associated nerve terminal down
here, or the associated
either horizontal cell
or bipolar cell down here.
So in each case,
you have obviously
the synapse here
is a little gap.
And you have synaptic
vesicles that
contain the neurotransmitter.
And they're indicated
here in the photoreceptor.
SV is the vesicle.
And inside that vesicle
is the neurotransmitter.
When the receptor
cell depolarizes,
these synaptic vesicles
fuse and release
their neurotransmitter
into the cleft and fire
or activate their
post-synaptic element.
In the case of the hair cell,
the auditory nerve fiber.
This structure here is
called the synaptic ribbon.
And it's supposed to coordinate
the release of the vesicles.
And they call it a
ribbon in the hair cell
here, even though it looks
like a big which ball.
It doesn't look like
a ribbon at all.
But it's called a
ribbon, because it
has the same molecular basis.
It has a lot of interesting
proteins and mechanisms
to coordinate the release
of these neurotransmitter
vesicles, which presumably
are synthesize up here
in the cytoplasm and are
brought down to the ribbon
and coordinated and released
at the hair cell to nerve fiber
synapse.
So I just wanted to
show you the look
of the synapse in the
electron microscope.
So that's what it looks like.
And the next slide
here is this schematic
of the two types of hair cells,
inner hair cells and the three
rows of outer hair cells, and
their associated nerve fibers.
And I think I mentioned
last time that almost all
of the nerve fibers, the ones
that are sending messages
to the brain at least, are
associated with the inner hair
cells.
So you can see how many
individual terminals there
are-- as many as 20 on a
single inner hair cell.
By contrast, the outer
hair cells-- you can see,
well, this one
has three of them.
But they're all coming
from the same fiber, which
also innervates the
neighboring hair cells.
So there are very few
of these so-called type
two auditory nerve fibers.
Here are the numbers.
So this total is in cats.
Cats have more nerve
fibers than humans,
a total of maybe 50,000.
About 45,000 of them are
the type ones, associated
with inner hair
cells, and only 5,000
or the type twos associated
with outer hair cells.
So you can see by
this ratio then
that most of the information
is being sent into the brain
by the type one fibers, sending
messages from the inner hair
cells.
Those axons of the type
one fibers are thick.
They have a myelin
covering, compared
to the type two fibers,
which are very thin
and they're unmyelinated.
And actually, one of the very
interesting unknown facts
about the auditory system
is that as far as we know,
no recordings have ever been
made to sample the type two
responses to sound.
Do they respond to
different frequencies?
Are they widely tuned?
Narrowly tune?
We don't know that at all.
And it turns out that it's
just very difficult to sample
from such thin axons as you
find in the type two fibers.
So I actually have a grant
submitted to the National
Institute of Health to use
a special type of electrodes
to record from the type twos.
I think it's being
reviewed next week.
And I hope it gets funded
because then maybe I'll
figure out this mystery.
But it will be challenging
not only because they're thin,
but because there
are fewer of them.
So when I talk about auditory
nerve fiber recordings
for this class, I'm going to
be talking about the type ones.
That's the only kind we know of.
And here is an example tuning
curve or receptive field
for a type one
auditory nerve fiber.
Now, I think Peter
Schiller probably
talked about single
unit recordings
with micro electrodes.
So you have your nerve.
It could be the optic nerve.
It could be the
auditory nerve, which
is what we're talking about.
You have a microelectrode,
which is put into the nerve.
And the tip of
the microelectrode
is very, very tiny.
It could be less than 1
micrometer in diameter.
And usually the electrode
is filled with a conducting
solution like
potassium chloride.
And the pipette that's
filled with a KCL
comes out to a big open end.
And you can stick a wire in here
and run it to your amplifier
and record the so-called spikes.
You guys talked
about spikes, right?
So you're recording the
spikes, AKA action potentials,
AKA impulses.
And if you want to do
this in a dramatic way,
you send this signal
also to a loud speaker
and you listen to them.
And maybe we'll
have a demonstration
at the end of the year on these.
It's pretty nice
to listen to that.
So you put your
electrode in there.
And you move it
around until you have
what's called a single unit.
And why is it called
a single unit?
Well, in the old
days, people didn't
know what was being recorded.
Is it a cell body?
Is it a nerve axon?
Is it the dendrite?
What is it ?
All they knew is that
coming out of the amplifier,
they saw this spike.
And that's what's plotted here.
These are a bunch of spikes.
And it's called a single
unit, because most
of the time when you get
one of these recordings,
the spikes look all the same.
But every now and then you get a
recording that looks like this.
And this is interpreted as
being fiber or axon number one.
Here's another number one.
And this is a second
fiber that's nearby.
But it's a different one.
Maybe there were
actually two fibers right
next to each other.
And you could
record both of them.
That's very unusual.
More commonly, you just have a
recording from one single unit.
And the interpretation
is you are sampling
from just one auditory nerve
fiber out of a total of 40,000.
Is that clear?
So such experiments are
done in the auditory nerve.
In this case, I think
the experimental animal
was a Guinea pig.
And in this case,
it's recordings
from a chinchilla
auditory nerve.
So what's the stimulus?
Well, this is a plot
of sound frequency,
sound frequency in kilohertz.
And this axis, on the y-axis,
is sound pressure level.
So this is how loud
it is, if you will.
And at a very low
or soft tone level,
if this frequency is swept
from low to high frequencies,
there was hardly any spikes
coming from that single unit.
But if you boosted the
level up a little bit.
And you came to a frequency
that it was about 10 kilohertz,
there were a bunch of spikes
produced by that single unit.
Then if you boosted the level
up so it was a moderate level,
there were spikes anywhere from
8 kilohertz up to 11 kilohertz.
All that band of frequencies
caused a response.
Then at the highest level,
everything caused a response,
from the lowest frequencies
up to about 12 kilohertz,
and nothing above.
What's this activity out here?
I said nothing above
and nothing over here.
Well, there's some
spontaneous firing.
So even if you turn the
sound completely off,
these nerve fibers have
a little bit of activity.
They fire some impulses.
There's an ongoing thing.
If you outlined this
response area with a line--
that line is the border, say,
between spontaneous firing
or no firing and a response.
So inside of the receptive
area there's a response.
And outside there's nothing.
Those lines are
called tuning curves.
And here are a bunch of tuning
curves from a chinchilla.
And there are one,
two, three, four, five,
six different tuning curves.
So what the experiment did was
they moved the electrode in
and got one single unit.
And then they moved
the electrode,
let's say deeper into the nerve.
And now they sampled
a different neuron,
a different single unit.
OK, maybe got this tuning curve.
Then they went
deeper and sampled
from this one and this one
and this one and this one.
And the idea that it's
a different one-- well,
the response is different.
But also, as you
move the electrode,
you lost the single
unit, number one.
And you've maybe put it
deeper, a millimeter or so.
It's a huge distance.
And you've got a new unit.
The action potentials
probably look different.
That's a second.
OK, so these are tuning
curves there then
from six different single units.
And each of them comes
down to a pretty nice tip.
And if you take that
tip and the very lowest
sound level they're
caused a response
and extrapolate that to the
x-axis, you get a frequency.
And that frequency is called
the CF, or characteristic
frequency.
OK, so CF is a very
important term.
You should know that the CF
is the very tip of the tuning
curve.
And the CF is different
from frequency.
Frequency is whatever
you want to dial in
with your sound oscillator.
But CF is a particular
characteristic of a neuron,
in this case an
auditory nerve fiber,
that you're recording from.
And it's a
characteristic that it
has that you measured from it.
Many of these tuning
curves, in addition
to having a CF and a so-called
tip region, also have a tail.
And in this very high CF
neuron, the tail goes like this.
And then there's
actually, I think,
something that I dashed in
here, a dashed line here.
And the tail continues
way down here.
These experiments didn't
want to boost the sound level
to get all the tail above 80
dBs because of possible damage.
If you crank up too much
sound-- just like you
get a gunshot to the head
is a very loud sound--
it can cause damage
to the hair cells.
They didn't want to do that.
But you could see the tail
of this response area.
It's a nice tip and a nice tail.
OK, now, right away we have
a beautiful potential code
for sound frequency.
How do I know I'm
listening to 8 kilohertz?
Well, this nerve fiber
responds very nicely,
lots of action potentials.
How do I know I'm
listening to 1 kilohertz?
Well, that same nerve
fiber might respond.
But I have to get the sound
level to very loud level,
like 80 dBs ATL.
But these other guys over
here with CFs of 1 kilohertz
would respond at
a very low sound.
So then we have a
code of which fiber
you're listening
to tells you which
frequency you're listening to.
It's very important.
You judge an instrument,
like a violin,
by its combination
of frequencies.
A guitar has a different
recombination frequencies.
Male speakers generally
have deeper voices
than female speakers, deeper
meaning more low frequencies.
Female and children's voices
are higher in frequency.
So frequency is
essential for you
to identify what sound
stimulus you are listening.
Why do we call this a place
code for sound frequency?
Well, as we talked about before,
different parts of the cochlea
respond to different
frequencies.
Here is a beautiful
example of the place
map for auditory nerve fibers.
And in this case,
microelectrode recordings
are done as we described before.
But instead of just a plain
old potassium chloride solution
in the microelectrode,
it's filled
with a substance
called a neural tracer.
What are examples
of neural tracers?
Has anybody played around
with neural tracers before?
Give me some
examples of chemicals
that are neural tracers.
Anybody?
This one is a funny name
horseradish peroxidose,
abbreviated HRP.
Another one is biocytin,
OK, biotinylated
dextran amine, PDA.
There's millions of
them, Lucifer yellow.
You can tell that I'm
a tracer kind of guy.
I use tracers all the
time in my experiments.
So what you do with
these neural tracers,
it's convenient if
they are charged.
For example,
horseradish peroxidose,
this is a positive charge.
And you can apply positive
current to the pipette up here.
That's going to tend to
force positive charge
out the tip of the electrode.
You can expel a
positive ion out the tip
by this technique, which
is called iontophoresis.
And if it happens
that your tip is
close to or ideally inside
an axon, some of that HRP
is going to come out
the tip of the electrode
and go into the axon.
And why did we pick HRP?
Because it's picked up by
chemical transport systems
that transport
things along axons.
And there are several of these.
There's fast axonal transport.
There's slow.
There's medium.
There's a whole
bunch of systems,
because this axon is
coming from a cell here.
It's connected to the cell body.
In the cell body you make
things like neurotransmitter,
because that's where
you can make protein.
And that neurotransmitter
has to get down
to the tip of the axon, which in
the case of the auditory nerve
is in the cochlear
nucleus of the brain.
So there are all these transport
systems transporting things.
And it just turns out
that some chemicals
are picked up by them.
HRP is one of them.
When you iontophorese
HRP into a nerve fiber,
it's transported to all
parts of the nerve fiber,
including to the cell
and including out
to the tip of the nerve
fiber on the hair cell.
So here is an example
of iontophoretically
labeled nerve fibers.
And there's five or six of them.
The recording site was
here in the auditory nerve.
This is a diagram
of the cochlea.
This is the so-called
Schwann glial border,
which defines the
periphery and the brain.
So this would be the brain.
So these are the nerve
fibers going into the brain.
They were recorded in
the auditory nerve.
And you can trace them
out into the periphery.
Right here is the cell body
of the auditory nerve fiber.
Every neuron has a cell body.
Most neurons have axons.
The axon was what was recorded.
And the auditory nerve
neuron has a cell body.
And it also has
a peripheral axon
that goes out to the periphery
and contacts an inner hair
cell.
As we saw before, these
are type one auditory nerve
fibers going to
inner hair cells.
And it contacts usually
one inner hair cell.
Now, you can know exactly
where that auditory nerve
fiber started out by
tracing it and by tracing
the base of the cochlea
through the spiral
and all the way up to the apex.
So starting at the base to the
apex-- so that's 100% distance,
let's say.
And if this were halfway
between the base and the apex,
that would be the
50% distance place.
This guy ending up near the
apex might be 80% distance
from the base to the apex.
OK, does everybody see how
I can make that mapping?
These sausages here
are the outlines
of the ganglion, the spiral
ganglion, where the cell
bodies are of the
auditory nerve fibers.
So what good is that mapping?
Well, before we put the HRP in,
we measured the tuning curve.
And we got the CF
from the tuning curve.
So we measured the CF.
We injected the neurotransmitter
to label the auditory nerve
fiber.
And we reconstructed
where the labeled ending
of the auditory nerve fiber
contacted its inner hair cell.
Why did we do this
for five of these?
Well, in the
ultimate experiment,
you just do it for one.
But if you're getting good at
reconstructing the mapping,
you can tell it should
be about the 50% place.
And you go and find it's 51%.
You know that fiber was
different than the one
up there.
Then you make your mapping--
characteristic frequency
to position of enervation
along the cochlea.
And here is the mapping.
These are the CFs.
And this is the percent
distance along the cochlea
from the base.
So 0% distance from the base
would be the extreme base.
100% distance would
be the extreme apex.
And you can see this
beautiful mapping of CF
to position, almost
a straight line,
until you get to the lowest CFs.
And this, as usual, in
the auditory system,
this frequency axis,
this is the CF axis now.
It's on a log scale.
So log frequency maps to linear
distance along the cochlea.
Now, if the brain hears that
the 50% distance auditory nerve
fiber is responding and
no other auditory nerve
fiber is responding,
it knows it's
listening to a 3
kilohertz frequency.
Place to frequency
mapping is tonotopic.
I said that opposite.
Frequency to place is tonotopic.
So this is a tonotopic mapping--
frequency to place, tonotopic.
And why is that important?
Well, it happens in the cochlea.
It happens in the
auditory nerve.
It happens in the cochlear
nucleus of the brain.
It happens in almost
all the auditory
centers in the entire brain,
all the way up to the cortex.
You have neurons or
fibers responding
to low CFs over
here in the brain.
And if you move your
electrode over here,
you find they're responding
to mid frequencies.
And if you move them over here,
they're responding to high CFs.
So this organization
is fundamental.
It starts at the receptor
level in the cochlea.
It's conveyed by the nerve
into the cochlear nucleus.
And you have these
beautiful frequency--
they're actually CF
organizations in the brain.
So the place code
for sound frequency
presumes that each
frequency stimulates
a certain place along cochlea.
And I guess, if
you generalize this
from the auditory system
to the visual system--
if you have a
particular light source,
like that light over there, and
my eyes are looking this way,
that light is going to
stimulate a particular place
in my left retina and
in my right retina.
So you have a coding for
where that light is along
the place in the retina.
In the auditory
system, you don't
have that kind of a place code.
You have a place code
for sound frequency.
It's very different.
The cochlea maps frequency.
How can we use this code?
We're actually very good at
distinguishing closely spaced
frequencies.
And here is now some
psychophyscial data
from human listeners.
We're going to get away from
the auditory nerve for awhile
and talk about
listening studies.
Here is to graph of frequency.
And on the y-axis is delta f.
What's delta f?
Delta f is the just noticeable
difference for frequency.
Of course, we're talk
about sound frequency.
And how is the
experiment conducted?
Well, you have your listener.
Your listener is
listening to sound.
And you give them a
1 kilohertz sound.
And then you give them
a 2 kilohertz sound.
The experimenter says, does it
sound the same or different?
Ah, completely different.
OK, 1 kilohertz sound
and a 1,100 kilohertz
sound, same or different?
Ah completely different.
OK, 1,000 hertz sound
and 1,010 hertz sound.
Ah, it's different.
1,000 hertz and a
1,002 hertz sound?
I'm not so sure.
Give it to me again.
OK, 1,000 hertz
sound, 1,002 hertz?
Eh, it's just a
little bit different.
1,000 hertz sound and
a 1,001 hertz sound?
Same.
OK, so that's the experiment.
So we have the graph here for
the just noticeable difference
in frequency, as a
function of frequency.
And at 1,000
hertz-- that's right
in the middle of your hearing
range-- the delta f-- well,
it's hard to read that
axis-- the delta f
is about 1 or 2 hertz.
So 1,000 vs 1,002
hertz is just barely
distinguishable for
human listeners.
You can do that experimental
a little bit differently.
Instead of giving two tones,
you can give one tone and vary
its frequency a little.
And that's kind of
a pleasing sound.
Does everybody
know what a vibrato
is on a stringed instrument?
That's a plain A.
But if you vibrate
it a little-- that's
the frequencies
going back and forth.
Everybody could hear
that vibrato right?
Even though I'm changing the
frequency just a tiny bit.
You could do the experiment
by vibrating the frequency
just one single frequency.
Is it vibrating?
Or is it not vibrating?
And you get about
the same result.
That's what the second graph is.
People who are tone deaf,
not proficient music,
don't have any hearing
problems are almost always
able to distinguish frequencies
with a little bit of training.
The training is now here's the
task, that type of training.
OK, so I have a
demonstration here.
And we can listen to this and
see how good you guys are--
you know, naive,
untrained listeners--
and see if we're good at
distinguishing frequency.
So the demonstration is
a little bit complicated.
So I'll go through it.
It's going to give you
1,000 hertz, standard,
middle of your range
hearing frequency.
And it's going to give you
a bunch of different groups.
I'm going to go
through these slowly.
And in each group, we
have 1,000 one hertz,
and 1,000 hertz plus delta f.
OK, delta f for group one is
10 hertz, big frequency space.
And what you're
going to listen to
is A, B, A, A, where is f--
1,000 hertz-- and f plus delta
f-- 1,010 hertz.
And B will be first, 1,010
hertz and then 1,000 hertz.
Then A, 1,000
hertz, 1,010 hertz;
and another A, 1,000
hertz, 1,010 hertz,
just to give you a bunch
of different examples.
Then group two, delta f will be
a little bit harder, 9 hertz,
OK, so on and so forth,
down to group 10, which
will be delta f of 1 hertz.
Or seeing if we can distinguish
1,000 and 1,001 hertz.
OK, so let's listen to this.
MAN IN AUDIO: Frequency
difference file for J and D.
You will hear 10 groups
of four tone pairs.
In each group, there is a
small frequency difference
between the tones
of the pairs, which
decreases in each
successive group.
[BEEPING OF TONE PAIRS]
PROFESSOR: That's group one.
Here's group two.
[BEEPING OF TONE PAIRS]
PROFESSOR: OK, could
everybody do the big interval,
delta f equals 10?
Raise your hand if
you could do that.
Most-- some people can.
I-- it's not problem.
OK, how about your limits
for people who could do it.
When did you--
AUDIENCE: I heard eight.
PROFESSOR: About eight, OK.
And what was your
limit going down?
AUDIENCE: Nine.
PROFESSOR: Group
nine or delta f?
OK, so delta f of 2.
I cut out about
between two and three.
Well, for those of us who could
do it, without any training
at all, you get to what the
best results are-- people
who have done this for
days and days and practice.
And this is not an
ideal listening room.
There's a lot of fan noise.
There's some distractions too.
Ideally, you'd be in a
completely quiet environment,
perhaps wearing headphones.
But it works pretty well.
I'm not sure what it says
about people can't do it.
And there certainly are.
So I don't know
if you should have
your hearing tested or whatever.
But for those of
us who could do it,
you get quickly to the
best possible results.
So you could do a
calculation then on these.
We know what delta f is.
Let's say it's 2
hertz at 1,000 hertz.
And let's go back to
our mapping experiment.
So here's 1,000 hertz CF.
Let's say we're
listening at the CF.
And we're moving from 1,000 to
1,002 hertz, the best possible
psychophysical performance.
We can go up along this
cochlear frequency map
and say, well, what
percent distance did
we move from the 1,000 hertz
point to the 1,002 hertz point?
And I don't know where it is.
Well, it's about the 70%
distance place in this animal.
This is a cat, of course.
You can't do these kinds
of studies in humans.
You could map it out in human.
It turns out that if you know
how many inner hair cells there
are-- we had that number before
along the base to apex spiral--
and you know the
distance you're moving,
it turns out you can make
the calculation, the best
possible performance.
You're moving from one inner
hair cell to its neighbor.
So it's a very,
very small increment
along the cochlear
spiral you're moving.
That increment is
associated with the best
possible psychophysical
performance
in terms of frequency
distinction.
OK, that's the
cochlear frequency map.
OK, any questions about that?
Now let's go back to
the auditory nerve
and talk more about coding
for sound frequency.
So far, we've just been
exploring single tone response
areas.
So now let's make the stimulus
a little bit more advanced
and talk about
coding for two tones.
What happens when
you have two tones?
Well, here is a tuning curve,
plotted with open symbols
here, for the kind
of tuning curve
with one tone we had before.
So everything within this
white area is excitatory.
You put a frequency of 7
kilohertz in at 40 dB SPL.
And the neuron is going to fire
all kinds of action potentials.
Now, let's put in a tone
right at this triangle,
called the probe tone.
It's usually right at the CF.
And it's above the threshold.
In this case, it looks
like it's about 25 dB.
And it gets the
neuron responding.
You put that probe
tone in the neuron
is going to fire some
action potentials.
And keep that probe
tone in so the neuron
is firing action potentials.
And put a second tone in.
And the second tone is often
outside the response areas.
And it turns out that
anywhere in this shaded area
above the CF or below
the CF, a second tone,
as is illustrated here,
will decrease the response
to the probe tone in
a dramatic fashion.
Then, when you turn off
this second tone-- sometimes
called a suppressing tone-- the
original activity comes back.
And this phenomenon is
called two-tone suppression.
At first, it was called
two-tone inhibition.
People thought, oh, OK, there's
another nearby neighbor nerve
fiber that's inhibiting
this first one.
And they looked in
the cochlea and there
weren't any inhibitory synapses.
OK, so that was a problem.
They started calling
it suppression.
And they actually
ended up finding it
in the movement of
the basilar membrane.
So it's just something
about the vibration pattern
of the cochlea that causes
the movement of the membranes
to be diminished
by a second tone
on either side of the first.
Now, why do I bring this up?
Well, it's kind of interesting
in a number of contexts.
Two-tone suppression might
be a form of gain control.
If you just had the
excitatory tuning curve,
and you started listening in a
restaurant where everybody was
talking and there
was a lot of sound,
all your auditory
nerve fibers might
be discharging at
their maximal rates.
And you wouldn't be able to tell
the interesting conversation
your two neighbors were having.
You wouldn't be
able to eavesdrop.
You wouldn't be having
a conversation yourself.
So two-tone suppression
is a form of gain control,
where the side bands reduce
the response to the main band,
so that not everything's
being driven into saturation.
That's one reason.
And a second reason
is you can actually
use this in a sort of a
tricky psychophysical paradigm
to measure the tuning
of human listeners.
We obviously can't go into
a human's auditory nerve
with a microelectrode,
although it's
been done a couple
times in surgery.
But it's rare.
It's easy to do a so-called
two-tone suppression paradigm,
where you have the person
listen to the probe tone.
You say to the
listener, here's a tone.
I want you to listen to that.
I'm going to put
in a second tone.
I ignore that.
Don't worry about it.
Just listen to that
first probe tone.
Tell me if you can hear
that original probe tone.
Ah, yeah, sure I can hear.
I'm going to put a second tone.
Oh, I can't hear the
probe tone anymore.
OK the second or side tone
has suppressed the response
to the probe tone.
And you can use that
as a measure of tuning,
because these suppression areas
flank the excitatory area.
And so here are some
results from humans
in a so-called psychophysical
tuning curve paradigm.
And these are a half a
dozen or so tuning curves.
Each one has associated with
it a probe tone or a test tone.
The task is listen
to that test tone
and tell me if you still
hear it or if it's gone away.
The experimenter
introduce a second tone,
a so-called masker, at those
frequencies and levels.
And at where the line
is drawn, the person
who's listening
to the probe tone
says, I can't hear that
probe tone anymore.
Something happened to it.
Well, two-tone suppression
happened to it.
The masker masked the response
to the probe tone or test tone.
And look at the shapes
of those tuning curves.
They look like good old
auditory nerve fibers.
They have a CF.
The CF is right at the probe.
They have a tip region.
They have a tail region.
If you measure the
sharpness, how wide they are,
they're really
sharp at high CFs.
And they get a little bit
broader as a CFs goes down.
At high CFs they have
a tip and a tail.
At low CFs they look
more like v-shape.
We can go back to the
auditory nerve tuning curve
with those in mind.
And look how similar they are.
Here's high CF,
tip and the tail.
Low CF, just sort of a
plain v ad they're wider.
Human psychophysical
tuning curves
have that same general look.
Now, remember, this is a
very different paradigm.
Here there are two tones.
The probe tone is one of them.
And the masker or the
second suppressor tone
is the second one.
Whereas in good old fashioned
auditory nerve fiber
tuning curve there was just
one, the excitatory tone.
OK, so psychophysical
tuning curves
are obtained from humans
in the following paradigm.
We went over that.
These tuning curves and
the neural tuning curves
from animals are
roughly similar.
Now, what would you expect
to happen to these tuning
curves and the
neural tuning curves
if you had an outer
hair cell problem?
And this is kind of
the classic-- oh, yeah,
you can sort of pass that
around-- a classic exam
question.
Draw a tuning curve.
So you label this
with frequency.
This is the sound pressure level
for a response-- I don't know.
We can say whatever response you
want to-- 10 spikes per second.
Label the CF.
Here it is.
This is a normal.
What's the axis here?
Well, the CF might be-- the
threshold might be at 0 dB.
The tail comes in-- let's go
to our animal tuning curve
just so we get this right.
Oops, pressed the wrong button.
OK, so the tip on this
one it's about 20.
The tail is coming in about 60.
So we are starting down--
well, let's say it's 20.
This is going to be
60 dBs SPL-- normal.
Draw the tuning curve in an
animal where the outer hair
cells are damaged.
Well, you could say,
there's no response.
That wouldn't be quite right.
OK, remember we're-- this is
the nerve fiber we're recording
from, a type one.
This is the inner hair cell.
These are the outer hair cells.
And we're saying damage
them, lesion them.
You could have it
in a knockout animal
where they had
lost their Preston.
OK, so the cochlear
amplifier is lost.
What sort of a
hearing loss do have
when you lose the
cochlear amplifier?
40 to 60 dB, right?
Well, what's this interval?
40 dB, right?
And it turns out,
when you record
from a preparation in which the
outer hair cells are lesioned,
this is the kind of tuning curve
you find when the outer hair
cells are killed or lesioned--
a tip-less tuning curve.
At least from these high
frequencies that have a tip.
And the lows they
look more bowl shaped.
But there's a 40 to
60 dB hearing loss.
You're not deaf, but you have
a greatly altered function.
How good would this
function be for telling
the difference between
1,000 hertz and 1,002 hertz?
Not so good, right?
You need a very
sharply tuned function
to tell or discriminate between
two closely spaced frequencies.
If you have an outer
hair cell problem,
not only are your going
to be much less sensitive,
but you're not going to be
so good at distinguishing
between frequencies.
Another way to think
about it is that if there
were a whole bunch of
frequencies down here
and your hearing
aid boosted them,
you wouldn't be able to
listen to your characteristic
frequency anymore, because
these side frequencies were
getting into your response area.
So these are non-selective
response areas,
where the normal or sharply
tuned are very selective.
And what are they selective for?
For sound frequency.
OK, so the outer
hair cells give you
this big boost in sensitivity
and sharp tuning of the tip.
That's the cochlear amplifier
part of the function.
OK, now, how could we do this?
Well, recently, within
the last 10 years,
you can have a
[? knocked ?] out animal.
But in the old days, you
could lesion outer hair cells
by many means.
You could lesion
them by loud sounds.
Well, loud sounds
actually end up
affecting inner hair cells
a little bit as well.
So the preferred method of
lesioning outer hair cells
was with drugs.
For example, kanamycin is
a very good antibiotic.
It kills bacteria.
Unfortunately, it's audatoxic.
It kills hair cells.
And if you give it to animals
in just the right dose,
you can kill the outer hair
cells, which for some reason--
it's not known-- are
more sensitive to them.
If you give them
a higher dose, it
will also kill the
inner hair cell.
But you can create
animal preparations
in which the outer
hair cells are gone
and the inner hassles
are remaining,
at least over a particular
part of the cochlea.
And from that part, you can
record these tip-less tuning
curves.
OK, so that is
mostly what I want
to say about place coding
for sound frequency.
And now, I want to get into the
second code for sound frequency
that we have, which is
a temporal code that's
based on the finding
of temporal synchrony
in the auditory nerve.
This is the so-called
phase-locking.
Again, we're doing the same kind
of experimental preparation.
We stick are recording
electrode in the auditory nerve.
And we record from one
single auditory nerve fiber.
And we measure it's spikes.
Each one of these
little blips is a spike.
The very top trace is
the sound wave form.
The next trace is the response
of the auditory nerve fiber.
And these are supra-imposed
multiple traces.
And that trace is
with no stimulus.
So this auditory nerve fiber
is obviously very happy firing
long, spontaneous activity.
Then let's turn the sound on.
The top trace is on now.
This is with the stimulus.
And look at how these auditory
nerve fiber impulses tend
to line up at a particular
phase of the sound stimulus.
What's phase?
Well, it's just the
degrees, the sine wave,
as a function of time,
the sound pressure--
this is sound
pressure-- and it's
going through 360 degrees of
phase here-- 180 degrees here.
And it looks like
many of the spikes
are lining up around
80 degree point.
So a lot of the
firing is right here.
Not so much firing here.
And then another
waveform comes along
and you get some more
firing about the same time.
Now, one very
common misconception
about phase-locking is that
every time the sound wave form
goes through-- in
this case 80 degrees--
the fiber fires an impulse.
That's not true at all.
Here is a single trace, showing
excellent phase-locking.
And there's a response
to the first wave form.
But then the fiber takes
a break and doesn't
respond during the second.
And it looks like it responds
on the third and the fourth.
But then it takes a
longer break and doesn't
respond at the fifth or sixth,
but it responds at the seventh,
and not at the eighth or ninth,
then on the 10th and 11th.
So it doesn't matter.
You don't have to respond
in every single waveform.
You can respond in
one wave form and take
a break for 100 waveforms,
as long as when you respond,
the next time it's
on the same point
or in the same phase
in the sound wave.
So typically, to
get these data, you
average over many
hundreds or even
thousands of stimulus cycles,
where one complete cycle
is 0 to 360 degrees.
These are plots of
auditory nerve firing.
So this is a firing rate access
percent of total impulses.
This is now a time axis.
So we're just saying when
does it fire along the time.
And the stimulus,
I believe, here
is 1,000 hertz, so it's the
middle of the hearing range.
And this is excellent
phase-locking.
If you were to
quantify this-- there
are many ways to
quantify this-- but you
could fit, for example, a
Fourier series, to that.
And you could plot
just the fundamental
of the Fourier series.
And that's what's known as the
synchronization coefficient.
And plot it as a
function of frequency.
You could make your
measurements at 1,000 hertz,
which is this
point on the graph.
You could make them
at 5,000 hertz.
You could make
them at 500 hertz.
This synchronization
coefficient ends up
being between 0.8 and
0.9 for low frequencies.
And then it rolls
off essentially
to be random firing at
around 3,000 or 4,000,
certainly by 5,000 hertz.
So this behavior,
this phase-locking
goes away toward the high
end of our hearing range.
It just means that the auditory
nerve can no longer synchronize
at very high frequency.
So what's going on here?
The auditory nerve fiber
is getting its messages
from the hair cell, right?
Here's the auditory nerve fiber.
And it's hooked up to
an inner hair cell.
And it's sending messages.
What are the messages?
Neurotransmitter.
When the wave form
goes like this,
the auditory nerve
fiber is responding.
Ah, it's getting lots
of neurotransmitter.
Well, that was when
the stereocilia
were bent one direction.
Ions flowed in.
The inner hair cell
was depolarized.
It released lots of
neurotransmitter.
Let's go a little
bit longer in time
to this bottom part
of the phase curve.
The stereocilia were bent
the opposite direction.
The ion channels closed off.
The inner hair cell went back to
its rest-- minus 80 millivolts,
let's say.
And it said, I'm
not excited anymore.
I'm going to shut off the
flow of neurotransmitter.
The auditory nerve fiber
goes, oh, we're quiet.
We don't need to respond.
Go back to the other direction,
then the stereocilia back
the other way.
Ah, I'm depolarized.
I'm going to go to
minus 30 millivolts.
Ah, well, let's release
neurotransmitter.
Oh, wow, there's
something going on.
I'm going to fire.
I'm going to fire all
these action potentials.
It's going back and
forth, back and forth.
At some point though, this
is going back and forth
so fast that this just
gets to be a blur.
There is a sound there.
It's depolarizing the hair cell.
But it can't do this
push pull kind of thing.
It's not fast enough.
Even though there's a
nice synaptic ribbon
there to coordinate the
release of the vesicles,
it gets overwhelmed.
Remember, at 1,000 hertz,
this is going back and forth
in 1 millisecond.
And 5,000 hertz, it's
going back and forth
five times in 1 millisecond.
That's pretty fast.
And it gets overwhelmed.
There's a response.
There's more action potentials
with the stimulus than without.
But they're no
longer synchronized.
It gets overwhelmed.
And phase-lacking goes away.
We can distinguish
5,000 from 6,000 hertz
very nicely when we listen.
We're not using this
code, because there's
no temporal synchrony in
the auditory nerve at very
high frequencies.
This is a kind of an interesting
code for sound frequency,
because the timing
is going to be
different for
different frequencies.
Imagine at low frequencies--
and imagine just
for the sake of argument--
that the auditory nerve
fiber is going to respond on
every single stimulus peak.
Let's say this is 1,000 hertz.
And now let's say we dial
in 2,000 hertz, which
is going to end up
going twice as fast.
I'm not a very
good artists here.
But you can imagine
that the firing
is going to be twice as often,
if for the sake of argument
we're firing in every stimulus
frequency, which may not
happen.
But this is kind of
an interesting code.
Because if you're
sitting in the brain
and you're getting
firing very far apart,
you're going to say, OK,
that's a low frequency.
But if you're getting
firing very close together,
you're going to say, oh,
that's a higher frequency.
So is there some little
detector in the brain
that's detecting
these intervals?
How fast the firing?
Well, we don't know that.
But we certainly
know that a code
is available in the auditory
nerve at low frequencies,
but not at high frequencies
like 5 kilohertz.
So what's the
evidence that we're
using one code or the other?
Clearly, the place
code has to provide us
with frequency information
at a higher frequency.
There is no temporal code
at those high frequencies.
Down low, which code do we use?
Well, we probably use both.
That's another way of
saying, I'm not really sure.
But let me give you some data
from musical intervals that
might suggest that
this time code is used.
What are the data?
We have to talk a little
bit about perception
of musical intervals.
And we might as well start
out with the most important
musical interval,
which is the octave.
Does everybody know
what an octave is?
Yeah, what it is an octave?
I can't explain
it, but I know it.
What about on a piano?
You go down and hit middle
C, where is the octave?
AUDIENCE: The next C.
PROFESSOR: The next C, right.
You've even called
it the same letter,
because it sounds so similar.
But in precise physical
terms, an octave
is a doubling of frequency.
Whatever frequency middle C was,
if you double that frequency,
you get an octave
above middle C.
So we have some data
here for two intervals,
one 440 hertz-- two
frequencies, one 440 hertz
and another an
octave above, 880.
So double it.
And why did we pick 440 hertz?
So that corresponds to a
note-- just-- yeah, right,
it corresponds to
A. And I was trying
to think if the A is
below or above middle C. I
think it's above.
So what's important-- you
guys knew that right away.
What's important about that?
AUDIENCE: Orchestras tune to it.
PROFESSOR: Orchestras
tune to it.
So can you give it to me?
OK, I'll give it to you.
[WHISTLES] Sorry, that's A 440.
And so here's A
440 on the violin.
[PLUCKS A NOTE] OK,
now, how do I know that?
Because orchestras tune to it.
So for about 20 years,
I sat in an orchestra.
And the first thing you did--
[LAUGHS] OK, tune, you guys.
And what instrument
gives the tuning note?
If you're in junior high, it's
this little electronic thing.
But if you're in the BSO, what
instrument gives the tuning
note?
AUDIENCE: The violin.
PROFESSOR: No, violins go
out of tune like crazy.
AUDIENCE: Oboe.
PROFESSOR: Oboe, right,
because the oboe's
a very stable instrument.
And if the barometric
pressure goes up
and the humidity
goes down, the oboe's
still going to give you A 440.
So the A 440 is a very
important musical note.
And all these
instruments, of course,
have a whole bunch of harmonics.
This string is vibrating in a
whole bunch of different modes.
But the fundamental, the length
where the whole string vibrates
is A 440.
OK, so here's A 440
or approximately.
Now, an octave above that
is a very nice sounds.
It's another A. That's
A 880, the fundamental.
And if I sound them together,
they sound very beautiful.
And in any musical
culture, an octave
is a very predominant
interval, because it
sounds so wonderful to your ear.
And violinists, I can tell you
from experience, practice a lot
of time trying to tune
their octaves perfectly.
And if you've ever listened to
a professionals go like this,
and every time they
go up and down,
the octave is just beautiful.
But if you've been to middle
school or elementary school,
it's a little different.
Because sometimes when those
students play an octave,
it doesn't really hit
to be exactly an octave.
And now I'm going to give
you a demonstration that's
440 and not quite 880.
OK And it's not going to
sound exactly the same.
So here it is.
And that's an interval I've
listened to many times.
But it's not a desired interval.
It's a very dissonant interval.
And what is terribly
displeasing about something
that's not quite an
octave versus an octave.
That is a question
that the place code
has a lot of problems with.
Because, for example, along
the cochlea there is a place--
it's quite near the
apex-- for the 440.
And then if you go
more basally, there's
another place for the 880.
And there's a place
for the 879 and 878.
And those would
be very dissonant.
But there's no reason that
those two things have any links
to one another in
the place code.
There's a place for 1,000
and a place for 2,000.
Why do they sound so
wonderful together?
The timing code though
has an answer for that.
And here is some
data to show you
why those two intervals
[? meld ?] very good together.
If you look at
the spike pattern,
in response to either
one of these frequencies,
and compute what are
called the intervals
between the spike-- so-called
interspike intervals--
every time you get a spike,
you start your clock ticking.
And that interval is timed
until the next spike fires.
That's an interspike interval.
And obviously, if
this is phase-locked,
these intervals are going
to have a close relationship
to the stimulus period.
So here's a spike and here's
an approximately two-cycle
interspike interval.
Here's a short interval,
but it's one complete phase.
Here's a long interval, but
it's now three complete phases.
Here's another
three-phase interval.
Here's a one-phase interval.
You could make a very nice
plot of the interspike interval
in milliseconds, the
time between the spikes.
And these are the number of
occurrences on the y-axis.
So for 440 hertz it's
the dashed curve here.
And you get a big peak
here that's a multiple
of the period.
So at 440 hertz,
the sound wave form
is taking about 2
and 1/2 milliseconds
to go through one
complete cycle.
And these intervals would be
firing on successive periods,
which, obviously, the
nerve fiber can do.
But sometimes they
take a break, and they
fire only every other period.
And that's a double
of this interval.
And so you have a lot
of firing at about 4
and 1/2 milliseconds, a lot of
firing at about 7 milliseconds,
and so on and so forth.
So this is an
interspike interval
from auditory nerve firing in
response to this low frequency.
Now, let's double the frequency.
Now, the sound wave form
is going back and forth
twice as fast.
And you have-- no surprise--
firing, in some cases,
twice as short intervals.
So here's an interval
for the 880 hertz
that's about 1 and
1/2 milliseconds.
But here we have
a firing pattern
that's exactly-- within the
limits of experimental error--
exactly the same as
for the 440 hertz.
Here we have an interval
that's representative
of skipping a stimulus waveform
or two stimulus waveforms
for 880.
But here we have a peek at
exactly the same as 440 hertz,
because these
intervals are lining up
every other one for the
presentation of the octave.
When you put those
two sounds together,
you're going to get the
combination pattern.
And many of the
intervals are going
to be precisely on one another.
And that is a very pleasing
sensation for you to listen to.
If you look at other very
common musical intervals,
like the fifth or
the fourth, you
will have many
overlapping periods
of interspike intervals
in auditory nerve firing.
And those are very
common musical intervals.
If you look at dissonant
interval, like 440 and 870,
there will be no overlap
amongst those two frequencies
in the auditory nerve firing.
Now, let's go back
to psychophysics
and give you one more
interesting piece of the puzzle
here for why temporal codes
might be important is active
matches become more difficult--
and actually impossible--
above 5 kilohertz.
OK, well, how does that fit in?
Well, we just said
that phase-locking--
because the hair cell and
auditory nerve can't keep up
with one another,
the phase-locking
diminishes for these
high frequencies.
And there it becomes
impossible to match
because you don't
have this timing
code in the auditory nerve.
So most of musical sounds
are confined to the spectrum
below 3 kilohertz.
If you look even at the upper
limit of the piano keyboard,
you're sort of right
at 3 kilohertz or so.
And that's probably the reason.
It's a very likely reason.
Now, we have a research
paper for today.
And I'll give you the
bottom line or the take home
message for that.
And this is an interesting
neuralphysiological study
based on a psychophysical
phenomenon called
the octave enlargement effect.
So I wasn't quite
truthful when I told you
that octaves are the
most perfect interval
to listen to, because it turns
out if you have people-- if you
give people a low tone and
give them an oscillator.
And say, dial in an
octave above that,
they'll dial it in and say,
ah, that sounds so great.
But if you look
really carefully,
it's not exactly an octave.
It's a small deviation.
What they dial in-- especially
at high frequencies-- remember,
you can't do this at
really high frequencies,
but at 2,500 or 1,500
hertz, toward the high end
of where you can do it-- they
dial in actually a little bit
more than an octave.
And they say, ah,
that sounds great.
But it's not exactly an octave.
So this paper looked and said,
what about auditory nerve fiber
firing can explain this
octave enlargement effect?
The fact that people
dial in a little bit more
than an octave for
the upper tone.
So these are the
psychophysical measurements.
And they just give
you previous studies.
What they did was they recorded
from the auditory nerve.
And they looked at interspike
interval histograms,
like we've just
been talking about.
And they saw something
really interesting
at the very high frequencies.
So they're going to especially
concentrate in here.
They found that the
very first interval
didn't match exactly
what was predicted.
So this is a stimulus
of 1,750 hertz,
so toward the right
end of the graph here.
And where you'd predict
the intervals to happen
is shown by the
vertical dashed lines.
And they didn't fire right
on those predictions,
except for the very
shortest intervals.
And they said,
what's going on here?
Well, when you get to
very high frequencies,
what are we talking about
for these intervals?
Even at 1,000 hertz,
what's the time scale here?
This is 1 millisecond.
What problems do you get when
you ask a nerve fiber to fire
and then you ask it to fire
again a millisecond later?
That's a very brief interval.
Anybody know?
What is the limit of firing?
Can nerve fibers fire closely
spaced action potentials,
you know, less
than a millisecond?
What's the problem
that they have?
AUDIENCE: Is it that
they are polarized?
PROFESSOR: They're
hyperpolarized, right.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Because of
the refractory period.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
There's something called
the refractory period, which
can cause them to hyperpolarize.
So what's happening-- if this
were a nerve cell membrane,
is what happens is sodium
channels can open up
to allow sodium to come in
and depolarize the neuron
and fire an action potential.
And then those channels
are turned off.
And potassium channels
open up and allow potassium
to go back and
even hyperpolarize.
But these channels take a
little bit of time to recover.
It takes a little bit
of time for the sodium
to turn off and get ready to
fire another action potential.
It takes a lot longer time
for the potassium channel
to close and get ready to
fire another action potential.
And the refractory
period is the time
it takes for everything
to recover fully
so we're ready to fire again.
And in the limit, that's
supposed to be about 1
millisecond.
That's the absolute
real refractory period.
So when I was drawing here
things a millisecond and less,
I wasn't really being truthful.
There's something called the
relative refractory period,
which is a couple
of milliseconds.
And the nerve fiber can
respond, but it's not
going to respond quite
as quickly as before.
All these channels
aren't completely reset.
It's going to take a little
bit longer time to respond.
That's what's going on
in this very first peak.
Remember, this first
peak indicates firing
at successive cycles of the
sound waveform at 1,750 hertz.
It's a very brief interval.
And what happened is you fired.
And then the next
action potential
you fired, but you
delayed a little bit.
So the interval is
a little bit longer.
That pushed this one
up to the next peak,
so that this interval
was actually too short.
What the brain is
getting is an interval
that's a little bit too short.
When it hears that,
it says, I want
to recreate the higher frequency
to be an interval that's
a little too short, I'm going
to dial in a little bit too high
in frequency.
OK, because that
frequency sounds better
with this too short
of an interval.
So go ahead and read that paper.
It's a very interesting study
of how neuronal firing can
give you a
psychophysical phenomena.
That's quite interesting.
And it happens especially
at the high frequencies.
Octave matches the
low frequencies
are sort of as you would predict
as is auditory nerve firing.
OK, any questions?
If not, we'll meet
back on Wednesday.
And we'll talk about the
cochlear nucleus, which
is the beginning of the
central auditory pathway.